hey you guys and thanks for tuning into
eg live I'm Katie Krause here with Ross
and rocky Lynch from the driver era I
feel like we should get right into it
because we've been teasing this you guys
have a major announcement we do have a
major announcement should we roll the
clip first sup everybody yo its Ross I'm
Rocky
y'all let's have everybody die get your
attention
it's Ross and rocky we're the driver era
and check it we're going on tour I bet
none of you expected that we're very
very very excited we have a lot of music
to write we just wanna let you guys know
you guys are going on tour on tour and I
bet honestly nobody expected it cuz I
don't even know if we fully expect I
forgot like until now it's funny because
fans kept asking even us when are they
gonna go on tour are they gonna tour so
how did you guys make this decision and
what can fans really expect from the
live show we basically made this
decision because music means so much to
us and a lot of our creative attention
as basically has been put other places
like I've been in Vancouver doing
Netflix Rafi actually has been holding
down the fort releasing songs like lo I
don't know if you guys pretty good we
wanted to go on tour because we needed
to to get the ball rolling yeah and as
to what to expect
we don't really know cuz like you said
we have three songs out right now yeah
so it's kind of like that's what we're
doing right now
yeah we're writing we're kind of studio
making music but also like it's kind of
cool because that's the way the world
works nowadays yeah yeah it's um it's so
instantaneous sure are you guys planning
on releasing new music before the that
first March date comes oh for sure yeah
yeah we uh okay we actually just cuz
it's been raining a lot as you know yeah
and our studio flooded yesterday we went
in there we play a little hockey in the
morning went in there around like
noon and there's just water everywhere
we're like what the hell and like came
under the garage because we turn the
garage into you did you guys lose
equipment I mean is there Dana man no
it's it like went along the outers like
outside of it so it's just kind of
something like the carp like I don't
really know we may have to take
everything out at some point because it
may be moldy or the good stuff was
protected everything was about yeah you
guys are no strangers to touring though
of course with our five how do you think
this will be different and will the
family be along for the ride at all will
they hop up on stage the main thing
that's different is this is actually our
first band you're going in a van yeah
East Coast all the way to the west coast
well we do we do the East Coast and then
I think we'll probably fly back la for
like a week or something and then go
from there to the back to California to
Seattle will you be doing the whole like
sleep in hotels things I'm not sure
maybe half and half yeah I mean we've
done a fair share of van life because
like you said like we come from a big
family
yeah and when we were first moving out
to California we made that trip from
Colorado to California and back like
maybe 20 times but we were just like
sleep in the van yeah so I don't think
it'll be too far out of our comfort zone
okay but but yeah we're taking the van
we'll have maybe a few special
appearances yeah from the family for
sure maybe close homey some friends yeah
who knows can you tease maybe one
special guest one special guest yes yeah
it'll be the same guitar tech that if
you've seen us live you know who this
guy he's actually kind of notorious he's
a couple shows he's actually
roller-skated on and offstage to like
pass guitars and whatnot yeah he that
goes way back he was like slashes every
worked with slash he worked with the
talent I feel like he's just a road
warrior okay yeah he's a legend
so it's gonna be a full band tour though
right it's not like an acoustic or is no
no no it'll be it'll be like we do it
yeah this bass player dude going and
saying yeah how are you guys choosing
the setlist well we as we said earlier
have a lot of songs to write that'll be
how we decided Salas and we'll decide
covers and stuff that we yeah we also we
put a couple festivals last year did one
in Florida yeah yeah we played in
Florida we played Maine America and
Philly we played in Seattle - yeah
Seattle and there was a couple songs
that we actually finished we just have
release that we played at those shows
that were fun and we were going to cover
so like they're probably a couple of
those we play a couple new ones
well play preacher man we'll play yeah
are we getting more music videos anytime
soon that is in the end plan yeah for
sure we'll definitely well now that I'm
back in LA we have more of an
opportunity to actually get some video
content to support the music yeah it's a
little harder when I'm doing Sabrina
sure but not I'm back like yeah we're
definitely gonna be doing some videos
yeah you guys have a lot of fan
questions in coming in already so I want
to get to some of them where Annika says
can someone just tell rocky that I love
him so much and I appreciate everything
he's doing more of a comment thank you
[Music]
Isabella says what about Europe what
about your yeah that's a good question
that's uh you can ask basically yeah
Sabrina people basically we're playing
so like only these amount of shows
because there's not enough time but if
there is if there happens to be like I'm
going to week or two the plan was to go
over to Europe real quick and maybe they
like you know
London Paris or something like that yeah
but it just depends on if Ross has time
sure what has been the biggest challenge
for you being in Vancouver and shooting
Sabrina when I was in the band
I think it's dividing attention because
you naturally get really involved in the
show and you want that to be the best it
can be
yeah but at the same time obviously I've
my hearts in music and I really want to
put some put some music out at the same
time so it's really just hard to to be
obsessed with the TV show and at the
same time be obsessed with music sure
because this one of them is gonna be
prioritized so I'm trying to work that
out right now and just try to figure out
like cuz I do have off days on some up
there in Vancouver okay and I do write a
lot of music by myself
I just haven't I honestly I do have a
lot of music I have a lot of music I
just need to put it out yeah what's the
biggest challenge for you are you guys
faced I mean er um it was weird we went
through throughout all of last year we
went through like times where we'd kind
of stay in contact a lot like I sick
like let's let's work on this song let's
let's put some stuff out and then we
kind of just like slowly like it's just
like like things would just like be
forgotten almost um and that kind of
started like went back and forth
throughout the year
and that's basically why lo happened
because it was like alright like let me
just try and like just do it let me just
try and do it so something good came
from it yeah so like in all it was a
very positive experience for sure but it
definitely is it's a strange thing when
you kind of you do like we do make a lot
of music together we did spend a lot of
time together and we what kind of did we
learned how to write with each other's
like like we kind of like fit the piece
of
this puzzle in a way in a creative
aspect that was very healthy and
something like we just basically had to
like figure out how to not do that
anymore yeah and then and then we
basically just kind of like learned how
to create without each other because
honestly you really slow and you have a
lot of other great songs that you've
written yeah I got a phone full of songs
that I that I've written too we just
need to go under the driver era but as
solo songs in a way we'll see we'll see
the music industry's forever changing
yeah depends it's I think Spotify now
it's just gonna be like it's gonna be
like an Instagram people are just gonna
have I've been preaching this to Ross
like all week if he were you're just
gonna like this can be music up there
there's gonna be Denny mattering so it's
like we're probably gonna end up doing
that where we're just be putting stuff
out like if if someone sings it whatever
if it's an instrumental song whatever
it's it's like here's just something
we've worked on listen to it what does
that mean for plans for an album is that
something you guys are talking about
yeah I do we would like to have a body
of work to go on tour with mm-hmm that's
that's what we're in the studio working
on right now yeah how involved are you
guys with putting the theatrics of the
live show together it's it's all it's
all part of like one grand idea sorry
the album comes with visuals and then
stage ideas and it's yeah it's all one
more thing and we're working independent
now so that gives us a lot more leeway
with everything mm-hmm
cuz normally when you work with a label
like obviously it's kind of like a joint
partnership that you need to like they
basically agree on everything um but now
it's like now where the boss is
basically and so when something's not
going good it's our fault
if we're missing deadlines if we're late
if if there's bad quality videos
whatever it is it comes down to us
because we're not doing our job right
normally it's like oh what's up with the
label what's up with you know what I
mean it's easy to point
no it's you get rid of the everybody and
it's like oh it's it's us do the pros
outweigh the cons though being on your
own label so far it's just it yeah it
kinda I mean it could change down the
road there could be we may find like a
better solution that works you know
maybe with like there's some labels that
aren't necessarily like full labels
where they um I don't know if they're
caught like they call it but it's there
just like it's like single - single yeah
so like I could see something like that
working out easily because yeah I could
see that happening
as of now like I kind of enjoy what
we're like the opportunities we kind of
have right now just let's see how this
goes sure also we get to pick the people
like we get to pick everybody thank you
rather than coming into a already
established yeah your entity essentially
and then having to work with people that
are already there
yeah help so that's kind of cool
creative I would have assumed yeah yeah
you guys said when you were here I think
back in March that you wanted to
collaborate with Camila Cabello funny I
was actually that was a long time really
like what happened last one we came here
and that was the first thing in camera
my know like she definitely bring that
up fans were asking people love you guys
and they love Camila have you talked to
her at all we used to play we used to
play shows the fifth harmony back in the
day like way back a few years ago I feel
yeah yeah yeah like four or five and we
were always we were always friendly we
never we never like hung out or anything
huh yeah we know we'd like to talk yeah
we we said that because we had a there
was a specific song that would have
sounded really good with Camila on it
like yeah yeah there's this song that
like we kind of like but we also didn't
like which is the case with a lot of
music nowadays that we'll work on for
some reason it was a good song it was a
Justin song wasn't right yeah for what
we were trying to do and if you had some
sort of feature or just another
another something to kind of make it not
just so like hey this is like the driver
here because I really didn't fit it yeah
that's kind of why I like I guess I was
like that was the solution to the
problem with Camille like a van yes and
then the song would've been amazing it
would still make this happen maybe it's
maybe somebody else owns it yeah oh you
sold it it's a long story
it was he was attached to our to our old
label and it was like there's a lot
going on basically yes anyone else that
you guys want to collaborate whether
that you have oh I would love honestly
like I'm trying to work with Calvin
Harris I love doing great yeah I think
he's very consistent that's for sure
yeah well honestly we'll work with
anybody yeah imitations there pretty
much well they're the reason why I say
Calvin Harris is cuz there was um I
think it was blame it on the night or
one of those songs he said like he just
got a DM on Twitter or something from
like and he was like yo check out this
vocal or something and cow hairs like oh
that's sick I don't remember the exact
story but something like that happened
you tell me I could just send Calvin
Harris my voice you never know nothing
like your my Calvin Harris bro I do with
you Sabrina questions for you because
they're coming in and I also want to ask
you there's a lot of speculation right
now there's some social media posts
yeah people want to know Josh and Claire
does this mean you guys are Instagram
official what is it I'm official even
meaning are you guys more than friends
um you know when I first went up to
Vancouver you're essentially moving your
URI they pay you to be to be in
Vancouver basically and me and jazz and
a few other
of the actors really just hit it off and
we would spend every day together
okay so jazz is like my closest friend
right now your closest friend you know
words can mean yeah you know she called
you her favorite which I thought was
really cute yeah
the favorites favorite that's what we
always say the favorites family she's
everyone else's favorite but if I'm her
favorite then it's like I can do with
that yeah how did you celebrate your
birthday how did I celebrate my birthday
weeks ago
oh we were in we went to we went to
Vegas again
yeah the are the rest of our family
loves just like just they love Vegas
they really do you know every time like
like my brother's always like just there
like a month ago I'm trying to work so
basically yeah we ended up going to
Vegas and it's fun yeah you guys get
into trouble when you're in Vegas all
the time oh yeah yeah every time
something has something usually what can
you tell me about where season two picks
up after the holidays um so what did you
guys just see so now you've seen an
episode of Sabrina as it's so it's kind
of hard to keep track of some shots so
much in the future yeah and there's also
episodic so so much happens in one
episode alone right so we left off off
as you said no more magic right to
Sabrina because she gave you a grog or
something for your for Harvey's dead
[Music]
there's gonna be I don't know there's
gonna be some new exciting relationships
that blossom Oh in season two okay which
is a which I think the fans aren't gonna
be initially excited about but I think
they're gonna grow to love okay these
new relationships does that mean Harvey
and Sabrina find other people I don't
even know what I'm officially allowed to
talk about I can say it if you are yeah
yeah there's the every character goes
has um you know meets new people and and
yes very ambiguous with your answers
here I I don't want to get in trouble no
I get it do you think Harvey ever comes
to appreciate or accept magic it's it's
very hard for him because of where he
comes from in his ancestry and and and
all those things but I think he starts
to see that it can also do good okay see
at first you know it's it's all evil to
him right praise Satan you know all that
stuff but then yeah then he started to
see some miracles okay do we go darker
in season two very much so
Wow yeah yeah no I did but now Sabrina's
at the academy she's fully a witch and
she is loving it yeah so we get to see a
little bit of that how does that affect
Sabrina and Harvey um well she tries to
come back to Baxter high and and there's
just some problems with beautiful witch
now you know and should fans hold out
hope Oh me and Sabrina yeah yeah I think
I think um there's definitely hope for
the for the characters to reunite okay
is there hope that we'll get some the
driver era music on yes really yeah yeah
yeah I actually really both sides
actually they're both talking to me like
Mike on the music side they're like hey
man like whose email do I need to send
them some music or whatever and I'm like
well I want to do it personally
and then on the other side one of our
producers and the creator of our show
have hit me up both in there like hey so
if there's ever like a good opportunity
and you have a particular song like we'd
love to put on tomorrow I want it to be
a perfect fit mm-hmm so I've kind of
been holding out a little bit but I do
see that being very strong possibility
for maybe part three and four because
part two is already shot right and it's
pretty much all edited and they're just
putting the final two this is so
exciting like that feels like that yeah
there's this song that we called 105 but
that's not what it's gonna be called we
just called the session that okay and
it's got a on the show yeah it's got
this kind of like dark yeah
well you said 105 105 sick that's kind
of cool I feel like preacher man would
also go just because the whole yeah yeah
religious for sure yeah yeah and
actually the Roberto acquires a casa
he's a creative Sabrina yeah actually
really likes that song well if it
happens we're gonna say we started this
whole I have to call not to this yeah I
love it
um is there a favorite song that you
guys enjoy doing live these last this
last show that we played was the first
time we ever played low live super fun
just like because especially because I
had been listening to it it basically
was sound tracking all of my experiences
up until that point yeah and then being
able to like listen to it on your phone
all the time and then go play it live
it's kind of a surreal thing because I
didn't work on that song okay you did
yeah it was so it's big like having your
favorite song on Spotify and then
getting to go play alive in front of a
few thousand people yeah it's all so
surreal it's very um it's a great moment
when you finally take a song from the
studio so like a live environment so you
have like you have different people
playing these instruments you have
usually the drums becomes more of like a
live energetic thing so everything just
kind of barely steps up and it was that
was a cool moment reaction yeah and it
was um the second festival we played it
at was it was on looking towards water
it was on the beach so it was just like
you already got this kind of like like
this rag
all right two more fan questions these
ones from Twitter before we wrap up here
Brian
nug-nug n ugh says fill in the blank
2019 is the year for 20 nights Robin is
the year for balance yeah all right I
think it's also the year of vegetables
cuz that was my new year's resolution
was just like eat more vegetables have
you been doing it kinda yeah pretty good
we should do won't make a stir Friday
night
yes cuz those are so good dude I'm
trying to get those veggies in there do
you guys cook at home doing more of like
this kind of introduced to me a little
bit more in Vancouver yeah that I can
break that I'm bringing back sort of
like Taraki a little bit do you guys
cook together you and jazz well jazz
will jazz has come over and she's she's
cooked for Rocky okay how does she make
vegetables - yeah all vegetables which
was like money yeah that's awesome
alright last one your new music is
fantastic and I love the lyrics what do
you want to express with your songs
that's from Marlys it's a good question
I mean every song kind of there's
something new to express so it's I mean
the of the two of the three that we have
out I mean you know afterglow was kind
of more expressing this like no longer
this feeling that no longer exists
and lo was kind of expressing the
current mood that was just kind of kept
repeating that was like hard to get out
of and I think really the the I all
we're trying to do is try and express
our current or current selves honestly
whatever that is yeah that's what I was
gonna try and say too is like it's you
just try to be truthful yeah
with with I guess you like your beliefs
almost like yeah because there's a lot
like there's a lot but I feel like we've
learned apart from each other now that
we can almost teach each other
sure like even through the music yeah
it's a case-by-case thing yeah I love
that yeah and sometimes like even John
Lennon said this work you'll write a
song and the meaning will come later
[Music]
that happens yeah yeah yeah for sure
okay
well why do you guys tell people where
they can check out the tour dates and
get tickets and all that stuff
it's a good question probably the driver
Ericom think yeah almost know what you
should do this is what you should do
what's that we our website and mine has
all the tour dates well I think the
tickets are sold not on the website so
I'm just guessing I don't they know go
to my Instagram go to Rocky's Instagram
go down driver eras Instagram and you
line.com
all the tour dates are on and they can
listen to you on Spotify iTunes YouTube
when is the next video when a drop do
you know we don't have a shot yet but
yeah there was will it be furlough
basically our current um are like close
team members are like yo lows like
starting to do this thing on alternative
radio like we need a video like this is
just this is me emailing where's the
video and it was a I was like that was
like two months ago I sick like we'll
get something but him and I we tend to
just dive way too deep and be like yeah
it's got to be like weird if we try and
go too far and so basically that was the
initial idea yeah still could happen
still don't still see what's going on
but yeah well for now we have the behind
the scenes video to hold us yes over
yeah thank you guys so much for being
here as always and I can't wait to check
out a live show you guys are coming to
LA yeah right now playing the griddle
Roxy yeah we like Roxy we got some
friends there yeah well thank you guys
so much thank you guys for watching make
sure to keep up with the driver era with
Ross with rocky and of course subscribe
to all things et
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you